32 jours sans pluie la France a
enregistrée la plus longue sécheresse
mythologique depuis le début des mesures
en 1959 les précipitations attendues
aujourd'hui et demain ne devrait pas
combler ce déficit plus géométrique de
l'ordre de 50 % pour le mois de février
le ministre de la transition écologique
chez Christophe Béchu indique ce matin
que des mesures de restriction de
l'usage de l'eau pourrait être prise dès
le mois de mars dès la semaine prochaine
plusieurs régions pourraient connaître
ses restrictions aujourd'hui 20
départements ici en rouge voit le niveau
de leurs cours d'eau très bas par
rapport à la normale de saison des
futurs restrictions qui planent comme
une menace pour se céréalier du Tarn la
semence de son maïs doit débuter dans
les prochains jours une image incroyable
dans certains supermarchés du
Royaume-Uni ou la crise économique se
durcit encore certains magasins touchés
par une pénurie de fruits et de légumes
rationnent à 2 ou 3 le nombre de
produits par client en cause la
sécheresse dans le sud de l'Europe et
[Musique]
il y a plein de trucs bons à droite à
gauche il y a des bonbons il y a du pain
mais avec son père là on va s'acheter
quoi une vieille pomme dégueulasse alors
non bien manger coûte moins cher que la
malbouffe l'inflation sur les produits
alimentaires était de 12% l'année
dernière en France elle n'était que
entre guillemets elle n'était que de
8,3% pour les produits sains en France
3/4 des nappes phréatiques présentent
aujourd'hui un niveau plus bas que la
moyenne en rouge orange et jaune parmi
les régions les plus touchées le
Limousin la Normandie ou les
Pyrénées-Orientales
et il y a urgence car les nappes
phréatique ne se rechargent qu'en hiver
quand l'eau parvient à s'infiltrer dans
le sol jusqu'aux réserves souterraines
en été l'eau ne pénètre pas en
profondeur et les nappes se vident petit
à petit l'ultime espoir l'arrivée de
fortes pluies d'ici fin mars pour
recharger les nappes phréatiques on a
quelque chose à vous proposer
quelque chose
tu avais vu un film et puis tu m'avais
dit maman je voudrais qu'on fasse ça
prenez une grande inspiration
inspirez gardez l'air joignez vos pommes
de main regardez vos pouces
expirez descendez les pouces au niveau
du sternum et j'ouvre grand j'inspire
alors ce gars c'est installé depuis peu
à Paris une chose est sûrement il doit
un peu regretter la province voilà ça
fait quelques mois que je suis à Paris
je pense que je faisais montrer les
coachs parisien donc c'est avec plaisir
j'ai pris les apiments c'est tout pardon
merci à vous aussi
on peut faire plein de bêtises moi je
préfère faire des trucs bien que des
bêtises
parce que moi j'ai un peu peur de ce qui
va me réveiller tu
[Musique]
manges un peu
peu on va commencer
[Musique]
personne va pourra les acheter et on
peut pas cumuler nos perles donc en fait
c'est mort ça veut dire que on aura
encore pas de feu et c'est l'horreur
tout est très cher c'est la crise aux
Philippines de toute évidence mais on va
parler de choucroute vous avez
complètement raison mais j'ai réalisé un
rêve de chroniqueur gastronomique vol
au-dessus d'une cuve de choucroute
regardez on est en Alsace on est dans
une plaine merveilleuse ou dans un
endroit
choucroute de France
[Applaudissements]
et on les invite enfin pour limiter
[Musique]
non elle est bien
écrans là on est dans une startup ou
comment ça se passe chambre de Lenny il
y a un ordinateur un écran de télévision
un ordinateur portable de téléphone ça
fait beaucoup quand même pour un enfant
de 7 ans dans une petite chambre comme
ça ce mec voulait juste nous montrer son
nouveau bermuda
[Musique]
l'habitude des panneaux pour les risques
d'avalanches il faudrait peut-être en
mettre aussi pour les tirs Festivent
les influenceurs tu aimes bien tu les
regardes souvent
ça fait mal au cœur pour Lenny les
influenceurs à cet temps je pense pas
que ça soit très recommandé pour moi
c'est un vrai problème on prend une
pomme et du ketchup mais non
je te jure ils vont le partager
le riz au ketchup ok mais on a même pas
de feu on peut même pas manger de riz
donc en fait ce sera que du ketchup du
ketchup ou ketchup mais ça sert à rien